in five eighty five four three stock
talk cosmic queries Mia more with me
here in studio you can see my favorite
line what is that star talk cosmic Larry
is it exists in the dark so we left off
talking about ugly book I was the
question was who's the most science
friendly president yeah I'd have to say
given all the things that presidents
have done and there you know Jefferson
was quite scientifically literate
president president Obama has mentioned
signs in practically every speech he's
given that's I know I'm still waiting
for the money on that and yeah and
Republicans in the second half of the
twentieth century
tended to give more money to science
because science was viewed as an engine
of our national security so it wasn't so
much that they were curious about the
frontier but just that science was good
for war this essentially and for winning
wars so but Lincoln there's another bit
about Lincoln Lincoln was as we know
about self talk and so many things well
when he was a youth all right you too in
1833 to be precise there was a there was
a mondo meteor shower effect a meteor
storm that landed meteors the earth is
passing through this stream of debris
leftover from comet tempel-tuttle and
when you pass through the debris you get
a meteor shower
if you pass through this especially
dense part of that debris you get a
meteor storm and the meteors are
dropping out of the sky they're going
like many times a minute and this is
before photography so people like their
wood cuts of this and it looks like a
star burst from from a a fireworks
display at the time the preacher down
the road saw this and started awakening
everyone saying it is wake up repent the
end is near why what one of this one
because in Revelation it says clearly
that one of the signs that the world
will end is that stars will fall from
the sky and drop to
ground so he saw these falling stars and
said the world is ending Leakey wakes up
Lincoln Lincoln goes out looks up at the
night sky notices that all the
constellations that he had memorized are
still there therefore stars are not
falling out of the sky then he went back
and went back to sleep but back to bed